short-term rentals could soon become
legal in clark county thanks for staying
with us here at 6 30 i'm denise valdez
and i'm brian loftis that item was
discussed this morning after large
community feedback helped county
commissioners get a brighter scope of
the challenges christian casares now
with the story
this is all about
us
in this community short-term rental
properties back on the table for clark
county leaders commissioner jim gibson
telling us the approval of an ordinance
is about protecting unincorporated
neighborhoods do it in a way that
provides an opportunity the opportunity
that the legislature is providing to
those who want to do this kind of thing
with their property assembly bill 363
requires clark county to make a decision
by the summer on tuesday county
commissioners were presented with a
report detailing possible hurdles
short-term rental will be listed on the
platform what we've seen more of is
more of the loud raucous
kinds of things we've had
crime committed in those homes personal
cri you know crimes of persons where
somebody gets beat up or shot according
to the report there are about 10 000
illegal short-term rentals currently
active around the county a lifeblood to
many families gibson says and also a
growing business i don't know that there
would be
much opposition to this at all
or maybe the right word is much concern
about
this at all if we hadn't had a fair
amount of experience with
party homes and disruptive activities in
neighborhoods short-term rentals were
banned years ago but last year state
lawmakers approved a law which forced
the county to regulate them now the
clock is ticking on how to enforce this
growing demand christian casa is live
local now